Crash's at dawn had the spot which marks
the very heart of this long conflict
Palestinians arriving for morning
prayers at their Alex a mosque in
skirmishes with the Israeli police on
their Temple Mount by noon things had
calmed just a little in the crowd an
elderly man was ushered into the mosque
courtyard Imam at creamer Sabri is the
former Grand Mufti of Jerusalem
now he's banned from the site accused of
incitement by the Israelis but today his
followers managed to carry him in it is
all a hint of a rise in tensions
just hours after Donald Trump said he
will soon reveal his peace plan outside
other worshippers who were banned from
what they consider to be their own
sacred ground among them dr. Nadia
Becker at I think he did not see what
happened here and in the Palestine and
in Jerusalem here the idea that all of
this place could be officially the
capital of the Jewish state of Israel is
beyond anything they can comprehend the
elderly Imam after prayers told us that
trumps plan is not for peace it's for us
to surrender he said Trump wants to kill
the Palestinian issue the Imam though as
with so much here isn't without his own
controversy in his rejection of Israel
he has in the past questioned the extent
of the Holocaust
and stepping into the controversy these
past two days
Prince Charles a guest of Israel for one
day and the Palestinians for this the
second he visited the birthplace of
Christ Bethlehem's Church of the
Nativity his message was one of building
bridges in a town dominated by a wall
and he struck a tone of sympathy for the
Palestinian cause today the signs of
continued hardship and the situation you
face it is my dearest wish that the
future will bring freedom justice
equality
Palestinian President Abbas appeared to
suggest that Britain had rejected mr.
Trump's proposals thank you to Britain
for accepting the vision of a two-state
solution he said and refusing the deal
of the century here in the West Bank
where Israel's separation wall is a
constant reminder of the divisions and
of the struggles you won't find anyone
with a positive word about Donald Trump
he is already part of the landscape they
see an American president whose policy
is entirely weighted towards Israel the
Palestinian factions bitterly divided
themselves will now want somehow to
unite to counter the American proposal
mark stone Sky News in Jerusalem